[Music]
if you want to change lives
and particularly if you want to change
organizations and if you want to change
the world you need power
so they're really a couple of major
categories of sources of power
one is kind of personal qualities which
you can develop and there are a bunch of
them
one is ambition um and that's because
there is seldom acquisition of power
or triumph in competitive situations
without hard work
and there's not going to be hard work if
you're not sufficiently motivated
to achieve something so ambition is
fundamental because without ambition
you're not going to
be willing or able to expend the effort
required to be successful
all emotions are contagious confidence
is contagious
if you act confident people will believe
that you know what you're doing
and people will be more interested in
following you
and doing what you want them to do part
of being a leader
is you need to act like a leader is
expected to act
and so acting is a very important skill
for exercising power i mean amy cuddy's
book presence
talks about you know physical you know
and
expansive posture versus contracting
posture and the fact that if you
are in a more expansive posture you
actually feel
differently and people react to you
differently so body language
is important of course acting skills are
important and
speaking skills are important and the
ability to
persuade and influence others and
choosing the right words and to choose
vivid words
and to use vivid examples these are all
important components of the influence
process
everybody regardless of how intelligent
and charming they are is going to face
setbacks so the question then becomes
not what
are you going to suffer a reversal of
fortune
the question becomes what are you going
to do
when that setback arises
and the people who tend to be the most
successful
are those who have persistence and
resilience
and to basically wear down the
opposition
simply by keeping at it
energy is another thing like confidence
which is contagious if you have high
energy
people will be attracted to you i mean
everybody
can think of times when they've been
around low energy people and their
energy goes down
they're around high energy people and
their energy goes up so
yes you have to be energetic and you
have to have
enough energy to basically outlast and
outwork
many other people
if i want to influence you i need to
understand what rings your bell or
pushes your butt into whatever phrase
you want to use
so that i am then able to craft my
message
and craft what i offer you in ways that
are consistent
with what you want most people
worry excessively about being liked by
others
and they worry about what others are
thinking about them
so the first thing i would say is that
most of the other people that you
encounter in this world
are thinking about their favorite topic
which is of course
themselves they're not thinking so much
about you
people are going to evaluate you not so
much on whether you're likable
but they're going to evaluate you and
particularly in work organizations
about whether or not you're able to get
stuff done leaders are hired
to accomplish things and if you worry
excessively about making everybody happy
you won't accomplish very much
authenticity is and the idea of
authenticity
basically gives people an excuse to not
change
to not adapt instead of being true to
yourself you need to be true
to what other people around you need
from you this idea that you need to be
authentic is
insane let us say you're an entrepreneur
and let us say things don't go well so
you can come in to your organization and
say
we've had this setback and that set back
and by the way
i don't know what to do you will lose
your employees your investors and your
customers
are you can do what great startup
and entrepreneurs do which is to say
we've have this problem
and i know how to fix it and this is
what we're going to do
and then you can motivate people and
they will stay with you
and you will have investors and
employees and customers
so if you are not able to put on a
positive face
in the face of adversity you're not
going to succeed as an entrepreneur
now we can call this lying we can call
it strategic misrepresentation
you can call it what you want but you
have to be able to convince people
to stay with you and if you come in and
say i don't know what to do
you're done
you see it on a daily basis that the
world is not a just and fair place
so people need to accept the world as it
is
it's an interesting fascinating
wonderful place and with sufficient
amounts
of intellectual curiosity and interest
in how the world works
you can get beyond your feelings and
emotions to be clinical
about how it is and how people behave
and how to influence them
and how to get them on your side and all
the things you need to do
in order to be effective to change lives
change organizations change the world